One of the best movers to watch around the courts...
...nearly of all time, I've seen some pretty fast ones...
...but what I've seen in recent times, particularly at the Australian Open,...
...it's so much fun to watch.
21-year-old hungry kid, doesn't show much respect for anyone,...
...doesn't really care who that person is or who that champion is.
He made his initial breakthrough in 2014...
...and it didn't initially work out that well for Hyeon...
...but I think he's coping with it a lot better this time.
He's a lot more comfortable.
He feels more confident in his own abilities...
...and his own ability to deal with life on the tour.
He's just a really calm guy.
He doesn't really get too up or down about too much...
...so I think he brings that personality on to the court.
And he doesn't let the outside distractions get in his own way.
He has shown that he has the game to move forward...
...and to compete with the big boys.
And he's much more of a complete player.
I think he's still very young, only 21 years old...
...but he's got so much potential...
...and I think he demonstrated that loss during the Next Gen finals.
After the Milan, first I got the win,...
...and I played really good in the last few weeks and this week as well.
And I'm just trying to focus on everything.
The first goal is I want to finish the season without injuries...
...because I had a lot of injuries in the last few years.
And the second goal is I want to do everything better than last year.
Now I like to play in the big stage...
...and with the top players while trying to stay calm.
I'm not gonna be scared of anybody anymore.